[Musique]
grand matin dimanche à l'étang saint
paul au programme pour 600 coureurs la
boucle du bassin vital parce que l'os
est vitale pour la vie et c'est ça le
thème transversal avec les gens de
l'office de lormont masse égale et c'est
parti
[Musique]
dernier message à la famille que tu va
survivre
oui cherche mon pied
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
mais patience patience le meilleur
arrive là c'est juste le vendeur
non
là
rayon par ailleurs
alors
ça fait rire et territoriaux
[Musique]
bassin vital serait trop long je me
renseigne sur les parcours avant de
défaire
[Musique]
on n'est pas à même pas la moitié ouais
on va fait très chaud
ok donc si les gens sont partis trop
vite là mais quand vous arrivez à bab
amr et pour dessein de la catastrophe
causée aux examens en soit voilà
d'accord vas-y photo pl il a besoin
voilà après sa magnifique combat faut
monter pour le mériter cet espace
naturel ce bassin versant
c'est simplement 20 à 5 espèces
d'oiseaux 13 de poissons juste dédié à
ce lieu voilà on est sur un un étang
côtier sous influence marine sous
influence t reste et c'est hyper
originale avec des espèces emblématiques
de la réunion qui qui vraiment ont trait
à la particularité de lille c'est à dire
qu'elles elles vivent une partie en eau
douce et une autre partie de leur vie en
eau de mer les celle qu'on connaît le
mieux c'est les bichiques donc on trouve
les deux espèces dans l'étang de saint
paul on trouve aussi des macros
crustacés comme la chevrette et l'acheva
keane qu'on connaît bien ici et puis
évidemment pas mal d'anguilles
[Musique]
hier le conseil
rayon des ragots nurieux rayonner way
jusqu'à la mort
descente et nos couleurs lyonnaises
fait pas cadeau mais depuis nous qu'on
va partager sans donner dé jacques déçu
profitez-en bien les gars s'excuse
[Musique]
vous êtes un nouveau parité pas rater
culture mais si c'est la cas comme nous
les olives terre de mixité tout pas de
religions réunies
vous voulez un neuvième on a chaud mais
nos missions parce que la moitié de la
course
on arrive dans la partie agricole des
goyaves au bord du chemin sont super
bonne et aborder ça mais ça a aussi
pareil c'est très gentil en tout cas
6 à la marne à représenter nos couleurs
il fait pas de cadeau mais remercie
bonté
cybèle cadeau c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
pas trop loin l'homme et saori pompe
ebooks papa matin comme on retrouve en
cours et elle a assez bien c'est bien
fait mon faux
[Musique]
à fos
correspond pas c'est vital cette année
nos murs par rapport à l'épidémie
bon bah pas de bassin vital vous
inquiétez pas on vous emmener quand même
le regarder pour essayer de comprendre
le cycle de l'eau en travaillant sur
l'amélioration de la connaissance du
grand cycle de l'eau à la réunion donc
il ya un lien direct avec les usagers
car ce réseau d'observation qui sert à
quantifier le ruissellement des ravines
va nous permettre d'une part de
mieux préciser la capacité de infiltrés
dans le sol et on sait que dans le
secteur ouest
la ressource disponible essentiellement
souterraine donc par exemple
l'alimentation en eau dans les eaux
donc aujourd'hui le département mène des
projets sur lesquels nous l'office on
intervient en quelque sorte à la
première étape c'est à dire que on
essaye de quantifier le ruissellement
des ravines dans les eaux pour permettre
par la suite au département de créer des
retenues collinaires qui vont permettre
l'alimentation en eau notamment sur des
besoins agricoles
[Musique]
toi tu goore bi classe était comment
devant les gars on et 794 à vivre un
truc comme ça ça qu'on voit les gens
diminué et puis qu'on entend c'est top
j'ai vécu un super boulot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
enfin de sauter de travail spécial
bassin vital une fois de plus le travail
a répondu à toutes ses promesses à la
découverte d'un territoire
là on trouve dans les sentiers
[Musique]
ouais
oui